we are in a new cold war with China and
we better start realizing it you have
said the Trump is gonna ramp it up if
the Chinese don't stick by a promise
that they probably can't keep so it's
gonna get worse you go to places like in
the Michigan and Ohio and Pennsylvania
and tell people good free traders I
guarantee you they don't share that
sentiment Trump's trade war is guilty
until proved innocent and the arguments
that Steve has put forward or
conjectural and speculative at best now
for the main event
and again the resolution reads president
Trump's trade related initiatives
against China deserve
broad public support taking the
affirmative steam war Steve please come
to the stage taking the negative me
which means I must recuse myself as
moderator and yield that spot to Dave
Smith for the rest of the evening Dave
please come to the stage thank you very
much gene how about that opening comic
he was great all right
so Jane can we Jane there you are can we
please close the voting that's that all
right by the way I don't really think it
was necessary for gene to make Stephen
come out again anyway okay so at one
more time the resolution reads though
sorry is it on the sheet I am NOT doing
a great job as moderator so far all
right for the for the affirmative
seventeen and a half minutes Stephen
come on up take it away
we have to put the resolution on the
recording president Trump's trade
related initiatives against China
deserve broad public support
take it away Steve great so you know I
just actually was in the White House a
little bit earlier today and just a week
or two ago I had dinner with the
president he had about 30 people for
dinner and that was kind of a fun thing
and it was really kind of interesting
because it was dinner and he Trump likes
to talk and he didn't have the
teleprompter and he's just kind of
rambling on and but he's very
entertaining guy and he sees one of the
governors because there were about
twenty governors at this meeting and
they were eating dinner and they were
sipping their wine and Trump just
interrupted himself and he said Oh
governor he said do you know that I
don't drink by the way how many of you
knew that the Trump doesn't drink I've
been around him all the time I never
occurred to me that he didn't drink and
so he said and this the governor kind of
not a sense yes brother never heard that
about you and Trump says can you imagine
me if I drank I do self more often so
when I first met Donald Trump which was
almost exactly four years ago I was I
think was January of 2016 the campaign
was just getting going and my buddy
Larry Kudlow and I by the way how cool
is that Larry Kudlow is the most
important economist in the world today
is that awesome or what we all love
Larry
and so Larry and I went to go see Trump
and he's you know and I have to tell you
that I had a very negative opinion of
Donald Trump at that time I thought he
was kind of a blowhard I thought his run
for presidency was just kind of a
publicity stunt but you know there's
something going on with Trump at that
time and I thought well let's let's go
see you know what I never met him you
know so I thought this could be
interesting and we went you don't look
down Fifth Avenue to Trump Tower and we
went up to the 63rd floor and spent
about an hour with them and you know it
was really he's a very engaging
charismatic guy I really do like him a
lot personally but you know we had a
long discussion about the economy Zork
actually kind of a good listener or a
good argue he likes to argue which is a
good thing
and the you know towards the end of the
meeting he said well I'd like you and
Larry to be my senior advisors on the
economy for this campaign and you know
literally our jaw dropped and I didn't
even know what to say and Larry kind of
broke this son silence by saying well
you know mr. prime you know I'm at that
time Donald Lee said Donald you know we
can't be your economic advisors because
you're a trade protectionist and you
know were for free trade and I'll never
forget Trump got very angry I'm not a
treat protectionist I understand a
businessman understand the importance of
global commerce and this and that and he
said but III think Amaris getting ripped
off and I don't think we've got a free
trade in this country and I don't think
that it's these other countries are
playing by the rule and he said I don't
think we have a level playing field and
what he said to us was kind of
interesting said just why don't you guys
just go look at the evidence just look
at what's going on with our terrorists
and these other countries terrorists so
we did and and I started looking at the
evidence and I you know lo and behold
this free trader look I worked at the
Cato Institute Heritage Foundation I I
was good friends with Milton Friedman
who was a unilateral free trader he
believed we should have no terrorists
regardless of what other countries do
and but I started looking at this and I
looked at the evidence and I could see
that
lo and behold Donald Trump had a point
that if you looked at the terrorists
that we were imposing on China and now
this is before he you know he imposed
the terrorists that he has we were at
about four percent you know our average
tariff on all goods and service to come
the United States were about four
percent and and China was at about
twelve percent or three times higher and
and not only that but you know the
biggest problem with China is what we
call the matter of trade barriers that
they had all sorts of other kind of
barriers that made it really very
difficult for American companies to sell
our stuff abroad and we started and by
the way it was the same with a lot of
these Asian countries Japan was they
appear worried down here the Europeans
were about twice as high as we were and
you know I thought well this is
interesting now what did Trump now
here's the more important thing when you
think about Trump and China and but by
the way as well as Trump and
you know Europe as well that his idea
what I call the Trump trade doctrine is
that the United State
has to sell to the United States why
because you said it very well we consume
everything right we are a you know 20
trillion dollar economy and most all of
that you know we consume and then some
as you just said
and so everybody every country in the
world needs access to America's you know
15 trillion dollar consumer market and
that gives the United States some power
and some I will use the word leverage
because we do have leverage over the
rest of the world every country has to
compete with us and as Trump used to say
to me you know Steve you said if we
can't trade with China we sneeze if they
can't trade with us I shouldn't maybe
use this metaphor they catch pneumonia
but you know so anyways you know and you
know there is some truth to that they
needed they need to trade with the
United States now I have to say I have a
big advantage here if we had debated
this maybe two months ago it would have
been harder for me to make the case but
the fact is the Trump got very very
tough with China he and by the way let
me just say as a pure political matter I
believe that it was the China there were
two issues that won the election for
Trump and I'm not saying this
approvingly or disapproval I'm just
saying it as a matter of political fact
the two issues that won the election for
Trump were China and immigration no
doubt about it and that's what won him
in Pennsylvania and Michigan and Ohio in
Wisconsin and Iowa well regardless of
how we feel about those issues I got to
tell you you go to places like in the
Michigan and Ohio and Pennsylvania and
tell people how good free trade is I
guarantee you they don't share that
sentiment those of us who believe in the
virtues of free trade and I certainly do
we haven't done a very good job of
selling the benefits to a vast vast
number of Americans and I was always
frustrated by the way with some of my
free trade friends a place like Cato and
reason and so on who would say you know
what's wrong with these people why don't
they understand you know the trade is
good and I'd say look if they don't
think trade is good they're not the
problem we are because we're the ones
who are supposed to be you know selling
the virtue
free trade now so Trump is using this
idea of using American power to force
other countries to do what we want them
to do and I have no problem with that I
have no problem at all I love what Trump
is done with NATO and he's basically
said to NATO look you want us to play
here you want us to defend you you're
gonna start paying more of your own
money for a defense and if you don't
were out of here
now that ruffled a lot of feathers in
Washington but guess what guess what the
Europeans are doing now they're paying
more because they have to have the
United States in NATO or the NATO system
falls apart and the same thing with
trade he's basically said to China we're
gonna hit you with you know 10 then 15
20 % terrorists on a huge swath of their
trade to the United States and lo and
behold after two years if you have to if
you look at the deal that was actually
consummated and and and signed into law
in fact I was just at the you know two
weeks ago I saw at the White House when
they had that kind of ceremonial signing
of that you know you'd have to say to
Trump one you have to I mean now you may
say it wasn't worth the price because it
did hurt our economy there's no doubt
about it the trade boy with China in my
opinion that knocked about half a
percentage point off of GDP in 2017 I
mean 2018 and 2019 and that's a lot it's
it's not insignificant but now where we
are is China if if if and that's a big
if
if they actually abide by this agreement
they will their their imports of
American products that is american-made
products to China will rise by about 150
billion dollars it's a lot of money
that's a lot of production that's very
very good news for American farmers and
our manufacturers and our technology
companies and so on that's a good thing
when they buy more of our steel in our
cars and all of these things and by the
way the Chinese love American culture
they love American things and with those
lower terrorists they probably will buy
a lot more of the stuff they'll buy more
of our petroleum products and so on
there's a lot of jobs attached to that
the other thing that China has agreed to
in this deal and by the way this is only
phase one I will I will concede the fact
that
is we are I've said this many times on
Fox News and so you know this is the
epic battle of our time well China or
the United States beat the world
economic superpower of the next 25 and
50 years I mean I that is the issue of
our time it's not climate change and you
know this and that it's you know we want
I do I you know you cut me I bleed red
white red white and blue I want the
United States to retain our position as
the world economic superpower and no
small part because China has gone
communist they've gone communist this is
the the red China is back and and by the
way that's one of the reasons I do think
we're going to out-compete them because
they have moved towards a
command-and-control kind of economic
model and somebody anyone in this room
show me anywhere at any time we're
commanding control and central planning
has worked because I can't find a single
example anywhere so Trump I think scored
a big political victory I think it's
good for you know United States economy
going forward and I think we're gonna
see a strong 2020 economy and it is also
true as part of this trade war with
China that is now in a stage of truce
I'm always asked well what if they don't
abide by the way I'm sorry I forgot to
mention the other big thing and the
trade deal is the intellectual property
protection and this may be the most
important thing in terms of the abuse
you know the way I put it is you know
for the last 20 years we've been in an
abusive relationship with China they
abused us they we opened up our markets
to them they didn't open up their
markets to us and it wasn't a big
problem when there were three or four
trillion dollar economy just getting
going but now they're in the second
largest economy in the world and you
treat someone who's now you know an
adult differently than you do a child
and so we are now in a situation you
know over the last 10 years where what
the United States what we produce most
of us in this room and people around the
country more and more of us produce
intellectual property you know
inventions patents copyrights technology
computer software all of these things
that's just a form of intellectual
property drugs vaccines we can't live in
a world where the second largest we're
producing this stuff and you know just a
new drug for example can gosh one or two
billion dollars of research to build to
develop that drug well you need a patent
so that you can sell it you seem to make
money on it so we can make future during
drugs to win the race against the cure
if you've got the second largest economy
in the world that's just stealing the
stuff and just you know copying it and
then you know selling it in China that
that inhibits innovation and it also
it's stealing rights just stealing
intellectual property is as important as
you know physical property so if Trump
prevails here in terms of enforcement
then I think this is a it's hard to
argue it's not a good thing for the
United States now you could argue that
it wasn't worth the cost you know
because as I said there was a hit to our
economy from this trade war and you know
my view is yeah we took a hit but you
know over time this is gonna pay big
dividends now to finally the question is
what happens if China does not comply
and I think there's a pretty very not a
very high but I would say at least a 50%
chance they're gonna they're not going
to comply they these people lie they
cheat they steal
that's what communists do and so the
question is what happens then and the
fact is Trump is going to you know
there's an enforcement mechanism here
and it's basically he comes back with
the billy club of terrorists and hit
some over the head of gotten with it and
the reason by the way that you know
people say that the United States board
the whole cost of the tariff I don't
know I'll be interested in your view on
that you know there are a lot of
economists who disagree and disagree on
that I never bought that for a minute if
you raise the price of you know this
there's a the fundamental law of
economics is that demand curves are
downward sloping if the price of
something goes up people buy less of it
and when you put a tariff on something
the price goes up so people buy less of
it and this is exactly what happened
with the terrorists we impose the
terrorists on them and what started to
happen is because Americans started
buying less of Chinese goods and
services relative to the amount that
they used to what started happening is
the factories started leaving China
they've left for Vietnam and they left
for India and they left for Thailand and
other countries because guess what by
moving a factory out of China when we
were imposing the 20% tariff and move
into Vietnam now they didn't have to pay
the 20% tariff for them that came in the
United States and I think that's what
spooked the Chinese and the Beijing
government
and President Xi and I think that's why
they come they came to the to the
bargaining table and I've used this kind
of metaphor before but you know I have I
don't know about you but I have to you
have any older brothers okay so you're
young rose yes did you beat the crap out
of okay cuz you know I'm the third you
know I'm not you know I have two older
brothers and you know so my whole youth
you know my brothers just beat the crap
out of me right and you know what they
would do is they would just bang the
crap but I mean then they pinned me on
the floor and they do that until you cry
uncle right and you know so I cried
uncle that's what happened with China
here you know they were pinned to the
floor and Trump you know brought them to
heel and made them cry uncle I think
it's a very positive thing for United
States I hope going forward China does
abide by this you know look trade is
absolute you you're not gonna you don't
have to argue with me about the fact
that you know when two countries or two
people or two entities businesses
voluntarily trade that's the magic of
the market by definition they are better
off final thing I'll say what am i down
to two minutes two minutes three I don't
even need three minutes
the final thing I will say is that you
know I started by saying that Milton
Friedman who was one of my great great
heroes and loved me Milton Friedman he
was a unilateral free trader he believed
that the United States should be like
Hong Kong Hong Kong just as a free trade
zone you can bring anything into Hong
Kong and they don't impose any tariffs
and so on and I used to believe that but
I have to confess you know Trump has
changed my opinion a little bit about
trade because we do have American power
and can we we can wield that power to
force other countries to play by the
rules I think in this case his tariff
policy has paid off and the irony of all
this and I'll stop with this I want to
see what you say about this one the
irony is that because of Trump's trade
policies we may actually see freer trade
and lower terrorists not higher tariffs
and less free trade okay thank you very
much
all right very good Jean seventeen and a
half minutes for the negative Thanks in
urging you to vote no on this resolution
I speak not only as a free trader but as
a libertarian president Trump's trade
related initiatives against China do not
deserve a broad public support since we
libertarians are a sizable part of that
public and of course I also hope that
non libertarians will appreciate my
argument I'll be talking about rights
and consequences because Trump's trade
trade policies are violating our rights
there is a heavy burden of proof to
demonstrate that the consequences
justify that rights violation and that
burden can't be sustained start with
libertarianism zkk or tenet the zero
aggression principle we don't deny that
it might be acceptable in certain cases
to commit aggression but since zero
aggression is the default position acts
of aggression by the state require a
high degree of confidence that some
greater good is being served in this
case we're dealing with the government's
assault on our right to engage in
capitalist acts with consenting adults
as both buyers and sellers the
government's double digit taxes
otherwise called tariffs clearly hobbled
that right call Marx thought capitalist
robbed us of the fruits of our labor
were Marx alive today he might recognize
that the state robs us rather than the
capitalists and that tariffs are one of
those ways but if Steve Moore and
President Trump want to call for a
voluntary boycott of Chinese goods to
pressure the Chinese into ending
policies they dislike then they're free
to do so
Trump has access at 21 million tweet
followers he can marshal huge support
for the
at voluntary policy I wouldn't
participate mainly because I regard it
as an inspiring win-win that stores like
Walmart can lift the living standards of
Americans by selling them cheap goods
made in China while also lifting the
living standards of Chinese workers from
grinding $2 a day poverty but I'd have
no right to call these methods unethical
since they involve voluntary action by
consenting adults but of course that is
not what Steve is arguing for Steve is
calling for the Iron Fist of government
to get us to comply to justify Steve's
Trump's punitive tariffs Steve should be
able to demonstrate beyond a reasonable
doubt that the leader was supposed to
trust with this trade war understands
the benefits of free trade yet Trump is
almost completely clueless on the
subject
he clearly views the Trump the nation's
trade deficit as a business man's profit
and loss statement in which losses are
suffered with Trent with a trade deficit
and profits are earned if there's a
trade deficit trade surplus I won't
insult Steve's intelligence by asking
him to defend this cockeyed view the
real benefits from trade come not from
exports but from imports as Steve knows
a trade deficit is made off for by
foreign investment in the US economy and
trade deficits widen when the US economy
is prospering not the other way around
so Steve is asking us to support a trade
war led by a president who happens to be
a bloviating ignoramus on free trade
that should be reason enough to dismiss
the claim that Trump's tariffs are part
of a brilliant bargaining scheme to
ultimately make trade more free as I'm
sure Steve will agree trade debt
deficits with China will persist no
matter what so Trump will always think
think US Inc is suffering
in dealing with China what about the
economic effects of Trump's trade war
well since Steve was once a member of
The Wall Street Journal's editorial
board he might agree with a scorching
Journal editorial that appeared last
month the editorial begins quote the
evidence of economic harm from tariffs
keeps piling up two studies out this
month indicate again that US tariffs are
paid almost entirely by American
consumers while illustrating how they
also act as a drag on US exports unquote
the findings are surprisingly dire when
the US levies taxes on imports in the
form of tariffs the foreign producers
affected often lower prices in order to
stay competitive but that hasn't
happened in this case according to a
started study quoted in the editorial
quote approximately 100 percent of these
import taxes have been passed on to us
importers and consumers unquote this is
not only hurting consumers but domestic
firms as well since more than half of
the costly goods are inputs domestic
firms use to make other products a
Federal Reserve Board study published in
December also quoted by the journal
included that quote for manufacturing
employment a small boost from the import
protection effect of tariffs is more
than offset by larger drags from the
effects of rising input costs and
retaliatory tariffs imposed by China
unquote the fed study also speaks about
the long term harm to manufacturing from
the trade war quote the increase in
uncertainty generated by recent rounds
of tariff increases may be one of the
ways in which the effects of past policy
persists unquote chump trumped signed a
phase one trade deal with China last
month whose main benefit is that it's
curtailed Trump's plans to increase the
financial bloodshed with stiffer terror
but under the agreement the existing
tasks have only been partially scaled
back so most of the domestic carnage
continues the debt the deal also
includes a bizarre provision that that
is based on managed trade rather than
free trade trade managed from the top
down that's the strange pledge from
China's government that over the next
two years its economy will buy an
additional 200 billion Steve quoted a
150 billion but the pledge is 200
billion which would involve a 45 percent
increase of three year in in China's
purchases from us that the government is
dictating from the top down on 200
billion more in US exports enriched
Burness purchase in 2017 which is quite
unlikely to happen and since it's quite
unlikely to happen Steve has just put us
on notice that if it doesn't happen the
the assault on our rights and the
assault on our economy by Trump is going
to be ratcheted up
so far we've dealt with the trade Wars
worth of salt and our rights and on our
economic well-being now let's deal with
three myths that have been used to
justify the trade war when a state wages
war against another state that state
often portrays itself as the passive
victim in the trade war the US has
declared against China we've been told
that the US has never engaged in what
Steve called the dishonest and dirty
taxes tactics that China has perpetrated
that mix myth is punctured has been
punctured by by groups that that Steve
tells us he reads by the Cato Institute
and by a a Wall Street Journal op-ed
whose headline reads quote America's
abusive trade practices unquote followed
by a subhead that reads quote China has
legitimate grievances to the World Trade
Organization often looks askance at US
anti-dumping tariffs
the article describes the crony
capitalist practices against China that
were ramped up under President Obama and
have continued to flourish under Trump
the tariffs the u.s. imposes on imports
from China based on accusations that
China is dumping its goods in our market
what exactly is dumping you might ask
well dumping is a case in which a
Chinese firm sells a product for a lower
price in the US market than is charged
in China's market so for normal folks
folks getting dumped on would be a happy
experience and the best kind of dumping
would involve a Chinese producer dumping
goods on us for free but in the world of
wonks dumping is considered a violation
entitling the victimized nation to slap
a tariff on the goods being dumped or
slap a duty as it's called on the on the
goods being dumped and in the world of
America's crony capitalism our site has
been able to claim we're getting dumped
on even when it's not been happening you
might think it's hard to confuse prices
in the US with prices charged for the
same good in China but then you'd be
under estimating the hired guns who work
for the u.s. industries seeking trade
protection from foreign competition in
the case of China there are often no
prices available in its home market so
the hired guns have a field day
constructing fictional prices from when
from which dumping charges can be
calculated there's an even more blatant
practice in which prices that that
contradict the US case for dumping are
simply ignored using a method aptly
called zeroing the author of the Journal
op-ed proposes that the u.s. offer to
end these trade abuses as their
bargaining chip with the Chinese but as
he observes quote offering a carrot
instead of a stick seems alien to the
blunt bluster of mr. Trump's approach to
deal making unquote US Trade
Representative Robert light ionizer
might also object if we admit to our
anti dumping scams
lighthouse er was a legal hired gun in
the anti-dumping field before becoming
Trump's trade rep this brings us to the
second myth when a state wages war
against another state
it generally portrays itself as having
first considered all the peaceful ways
of settling grievances in this case we
are told that the US can't use the World
Trade Organization to channels challenge
China's trade practices because China
doesn't comply with that organization's
rulings the evidence is that China's
record of compliance is better than ours
an academic study on this subject
peer-reviewed scrutinizes the 43 cases
in which China has been a target of
trade disputes from its entry into the
World Trade Organization in December
2001 to talk to December 2018 the author
finds that quote China has timely and
satisfactorily implemented WTO tribunals
in 42 out of the 43 cases he concludes
quote the China's record of compliance
suggests that the dispute settlement
mechanism has been largely effective in
inducing compliance he also observes
quote ironically while the US has been
accusing China of not complying with WTO
rules
the US has record of compliance is
evidently worse than that of China the
u.s. refusal to change the practice of
zero Ling has been a blunt denial of its
World Trade Organization obligations and
outright disrespect for World Trade
Organization ruling rulings in addition
while China has never been subject to
any requests for retaliation as a result
of failure to comply the US has faced 15
such requests which brings us to the
third myth when a state wages war
against another state it generally
exaggerated s' the harm that the other
state has perpetrated against it in this
case we are told that China's massive
theft of our intellectual property comes
to hundreds of billions a year and that
has been threatening a private sector
incentives to produce intellectual
property to consider the plausibility of
this claim take the figures on the
portion of gross domestic product
allocated to private investment in
intellectual property which mainly
consists of research and development and
software that investment came to four
hundred billion dollars in 2000 just
before China became a major training
trader in the world scene and has since
climbed to a stunning 1 trillion dollars
in 2019 at a record high of nearly 5
percent of GDP so of our domestic
industries feel sapped by China's piracy
of our intellectual property they
certainly don't show it in the in their
actions while I questioned Steve's high
estimate the highest iment that steve
has mentioned in the past of hundreds of
billions of year for here in
intellectual property theft it would not
be so terrible if we really were
subsidizing the Chinese economy to that
extent ironically our economy benefits
from the awful legacy of Chinese central
planning which is what is made Chinese
labor so cheap the u.s. bought 540
billion in goods from China in 2018 and
we easily got a 200 to 300 billion
dollar discount on that purchase because
of China's cheap labor but even more to
the point when Steve speaks of s
stealing our intellectual property he
ignores the difference between stealing
and putting that intellectual property
to some use given the heavy burden of
central planning in China that Steve
himself points out it's unlikely that
China will be put put much of that
stolen technology to any good use so to
a great extent such theft is not really
theft at all and so what are we left to
it we we are left with a situation in
which Steve is on the hands of a point
of a dilemma on the one hand concerned
about about China becoming a superpower
in technology as though we should really
care or as though those in those people
in England Canada Sweden Norway seem to
get along
just fine even though their governments
are not dominant in technology but does
he really believe there is much chance
of that happening in a country where he
himself says is increasingly subject to
central planning how likely is that is
that really something to worry about in
any case and is that really something
that will be very likely in any case so
might there be a better way well start
by firing trade rep Robert light Hauser
as a corrupting influence and put an end
to our anti dumping scams improve our
record of compliance with the World
Trade Organization and press claims
against China with that organization
that are legitimate and abolish all
tariffs since there are an assault on
our rights and on our material
well-being and meanwhile vote no on this
debate resolution Thanks
all right very good so we've heard from
the affirmative and we've heard from the
negative we will now have 5-minute
rebuttals from each and after the
rebuttals will we're gonna take
questions the debaters can ask each
other questions I can ask a couple
questions and most of all we want to
hear from you guys so we're gonna do
five minute rebuttal each and then you
guys can line up at the microphone and
you can ask your questions we do ask
that you keep them as questions and not
life stories all right Stephen five
minutes rebuttal from the affirmative
okay there was a lot there I agreed with
and a lot I disagreed with and let me
start with a think of a central premise
I know what Donald Trump would say if he
were here and I happen to agree with him
on this we did not start the trade war
we didn't start the straight or they
started this twenty years ago I mean
when you have a situation where our
average terrorists are 1/3 as high as
theirs are how can anybody in the right
mind say with the were the villain here
and the word you know this is why by the
way I think one of the great things
Donald Trump has done and you're a
libertarian why should we subject
our selves to the World Trade
Organization every the United States
should pull out of every International
Organization across the globe we should
never submit our our own palaces to
groups like that
so okay look this policy has look I told
Donald Trump it's a very risky and
dangerous strategy and it was a risky a
dangerous strategy but the fact is now
we are where we are we've got a pretty
good deal that is going to in my opinion
improve the United States economy and
it's gonna force China to lower their
terrorists to have a level playing field
and that's a good thing I mean you look
at the result of this you know there's
my parents you say the proof of the
pudding is needing did it work yeah at
least so far it has now I agree with you
that look you say the terrorists violate
rights yeah I guess there's something to
that but a tariff is just attacks a
tariff is a tax
I hate taxes everybody in this room
hates taxes I know there are a lot of
libertarians who don't want taxes I
don't want taxes I want to be as low as
possible but a tariff is a tax and I
don't see why it is any more of a
violation of your right to impose a tax
on a product that's coming into the
United States when you consume it then
when you pay your sales tax here in New
York right it's just to say it's just a
tax and you're consuming a product and
frankly I'd rather tax put a tax on a
product that's you know made in China
then one made here in the United States
you know so sue me
I know you come here I bleed red white
and blue I think it's you know we should
you know but I don't look my theory is
we I disagree with Trump on steel
tariffs I disagree with Trump on
aluminum tariffs I disagree with him on
Auto terrorist it's never a smart thing
to impose a tariff that's a
protectionist policy to help one
industry but I think when it's about you
know getting rid of abuses of other
countries then I think it is it can be
used effectively I think Trump has
proven that let's see what else you were
making the point about well this idea
about I just I fundamentally disagree
with that Wall Street Journal editorial
I did read it and I just don't believe I
don't think it's right how can anybody
who believes and
downward you know demand curves believe
that when you put a 20% on a product
coming from abroad that the full cost of
that is borne by the American consumer
as it doesn't make any sense and by the
way if that were true then China could
have just five years ago raised their
prices by 20% right all they would have
been why wouldn't they've just raised
their prices if the full cost of it was
gonna be borne by America's why didn't
they just raise their prices by 20% two
three four years ago and the answer is
because people would have bought fewer
their products and that's why the the
this idea that the American consumer
paid at all I think is just really bad
economics and I think it's and by the
way the reason we know that that's not
true is because if that were the case
why would China oppose the terrorists at
all if the full cost we're going to be
borne by the United States a couple last
points Oh dumping I agree with you
dumping look if companies countries want
to give us stuff for free I'm all in
favor of that so I think Trump is wrong
on dumping on intellectual property
here's where I think you and I
fundamentally disagree we cannot go
forward as a nation and continue to
produce this incredible you know whether
it's drugs vaccines computer software
you know new kinds of you know
manufacturing and so on that tossed
billions of dollars to produce there's
reason that we have patent laws you
protect people's intellectual property
because that actually encourages more
intellectual property a more enhancement
of new products and new to you know and
I have a just give you one good example
of how abusive it is in China I have a
good friend who's the head of Apple this
is one example and he said I you know I
was meeting with him he was the head of
the government affairs an app in
Washington and he said Steve how many
Apple stores do you think there are
China and I said I don't know 50 he said
there's no said there's probably about
200 Apple you know retail Apple stores
in China and then he said to me Steve do
you know how many of those are actually
owned by Apple he said about 10 of them
oh the other 190 literally what the
Chinese do this gives you a sense of how
abusive it is over there and how they
have no respect
private property rights what they
literally do is they open a store and
they will slap in it they'll just take
the Apple and sing me and put it on the
wall and say we're Apple that'd be like
you know you and I may I'm saying hey
let's open up at McDonald's we'll just
put the golden arches up and we'll call
ourselves McDonald's you can't do that
and it's just a microcosm what's going
on they have no respect for private
properties and we have to enforce our
private property both with intellectual
and physical property okay
gene five minutes of rebuttal and then
we go to the questions well Steve has
just told us which something I knew that
he opposed Trump's carves on steel and
aluminum he opposed those taxes he
didn't like him Steve that's great that
you feel that way and yet and yet he's
asking us to trust this glow va ting
ignoramus with these policies he's on
the horns of a dilemma Steve told us
that he used to agree with Milton
Friedman but guess who convinced him
that look thin
the same bloviating ignoramus Steve come
back to us about to us a look Steve the
reason why I applaud it I mentioned the
World Trade Organization I'm willing to
go with that managed trade business
Milton Friedman said we need a
constitutional amendment a
constitutional amendment will read
Congress should make no law no law
period charging period
it wasn't an anarchist Steve you know
that come on that shall make no law
which which will impose a tax on imports
or will subsidize exports period no law
doing that and we can become a beacon of
freedom to the world and we're rich
enough and it will benefit our economy
to do that and now Steve was persuaded
by Trump that Milton Friedman was wrong
well too bad for Steve you don't have to
be persuaded by Trump the way Steve was
and now and now why did I say that if
Steve that's why I said if you don't
want to deal with the World Trade
Organization fine like that all I said
was that we are the delinquents when it
comes to the World Trade Organization
not the Chinese the Chinese obviously
partly because that we could they they
have it in their interest to defend us
now Steve also wants us to to bleed for
the apples to apple stock by the way I
looked it up it was at 4.6 billion
capitalization in the year 2000 and now
it's at a trillion dollars so if the
Apple stockholders want me to pay these
ridiculous tariff taxes in order to
defend their rights to have more stores
in China I will only tell them as a
potential philanthropist there are other
people in greater need than they for my
philanthropy Steve wants us to stand up
to these guys the fact of the matter is
that we are a powerful economy and again
Steve seems to be cooler on the hands
horns of a dilemma he himself knows he
himself has the insight to recognize
that essentially planned the economy
like China isn't really stealing our
intellectual property yeah they're
poaching on some of the Apple stores
well I
I I'll wait for Apple stock to go back
to 4.6 billion in capitalization before
I start worrying about that overly
before anybody can ask me that the
government has a right to violate my
rights by taxing me with with a trade
war and then Steve is telling us on top
of that that if that if China doesn't
Bob I'd buy this ridiculous promise to
buy two hundred billion more of our
goods which is going to be a forty-five
percent increase per year which was
obviously just what was that what was
that agreement
it was clearly just Trump wanted
something off the table and then on top
of that what else does Trump wanted
something off the table he wanted this
trade were no longer hang kangaroo said
we've got a phase one he's gonna claim
tonight in the State of the Union
address maybe he had Steve help him on
that passage and we're winning the trade
war against against China you know and
and we're gonna be on to victory with
our phase one but it's not going to work
out the Chinese cannot ratchet up forty
five percent and that's managed trade
that's bet so I want to say to stable
Steve come back to us come back to us as
the pure great free trader you are
because we need you you're a talented
man well what else I mean again
amazingly Steve then disavowed the Wall
Street Journal editorial let's summarize
six different studies The Wall Street
Journal editorial said they keep piling
up and that keeps saying the same thing
from every reputable source and then and
now Steve thinks that that Steve has
actually told you maybe I can't sit
there this crazy thing that that the 20
percent 25 percent tabs would have been
imposed on the Chinese know they're
imposed on us but of course they were
also heard that means that fewer goods
are being sold the Chinese didn't want
to ratchet up their price but it means
that we are paying big time for those
tabs our rights are being violated and
there is a better way the better way is
negotiate through the World Trade
Organization clean up your app because
it is possible to do that or they're
even better way is come back to a steam
and become a radical for a change and
advocate Milton Friedman's view that we
had nothing to gain
and everything to lose by not being a
beacon to the free world and simply
saying we we have open borders with
spent trade thank you very much okay all
right so now we're at the the question
portion so if you guys want to ask
questions you can line up by the
microphones of course at any point if
you - are you a microphone right there
Steven if at any point you too want to
ask each other questions yes okay so go
ahead i'm ripper and ready to go there
we go I want to get to this issue of
being Americans you know burying
American consumers bearing the whole
cost over tariffs not the whole cost I'm
betting Oh close now you said it you
cited the Wall Street Journal which said
that the that the burden of the
terrorists were borne by American
consumers I thought that not the hundred
percent worth I would say you know my
point there is absolutely a substitution
effect that in fact what happens is you
let's say we put a hundred percent on
tariffs from China what happens is
people stop buying stuff from China and
they buy stuff from Japan or Korea or
Taiwan or Thailand or the or even better
yet from the United States so it's hard
to say and the people who are the big
loser there
there of course are the Chinese because
they can't sell the stuff and they lose
the jobs and Trump use that hammer to
force China it might but are you saying
there's not a downward sloping demand
curve for products from China Steve what
I'm really saying is that it's very
basically very similar to what you said
a bit I'm only saying that the Wall
Street Journal editorial made it clear
that certain things that make it easier
when tariffs are imposed have not
happened that the Chinese sellers have
not rolled back their prices they're
still being I know why maybe maybe
because of the government I'm only
saying that in a way I'm not that
interested in this because Steve you're
acting like a shill for Trump when you
say hey look guys I know that it costs
you money you've said that I know that
is painful but but look hey you know
it's hurting the Chinese - okay fine I
don't I don't wish to necessarily go
there I'm only saying that it's a
violation of our rights and a violation
of our material well-being
and when you say that hey look you know
taxes ya know we're all against taxes
but just grin and bear it because mr.
Trump are bloviating in Doremus knows
what he's doing I'm only trying to say
that's all of a piece
it clearly is painful you and I can
agree about the pain if we're a little
further apart fine it's violating our
rights and it's exacting material thing
and on top of that you have said that
Trump is gonna ramp it up if the Chinese
don't stick by a promise that they
probably can't keep so it's going to get
worse the burden of proof is on you to
prove that that this is worth it and
there are resources there are other ways
to go as I keep saying well a trade
organization or Milton Friedman what are
the other you know it's just my view
that we couldn't we've I am proud that
we finally have a president aren't you
for the first time in 30 years that
basically said to China we stood I to I
which I that said hell no we're not
going to be about this well well we also
had a president who ignored the fact
that ever since Obama and through his
administration we have acted like cheats
and and crony capitalists and exacted
duties on goods from China because of
this ridiculous anti dumping thing read
the Cato Institute report on that so so
if you're proud of that you should also
be ashamed of the fact that Trump didn't
own up to the fact that we act like
Schmucks also Steve and you also might
not know the fact that we don't apply
but we thumb our nose at the World Trade
Organization because we keep maintaining
it all right please do engaging this
[ __ ] do we do we do boss use your
pear-shaped out do we sit of course but
is there anyone like this idea that that
China has then you know the world trade
or gonna say that the China is abiding
by the World Trade Organization come on
Obama
think about 30 years every single thing
it does is violate the World Trade
Organization says don't work you know we
shouldn't be doing this come on all
right
I have walls
I see God I was moderate yeah I was like
oh [ __ ] all steel man Nick Gillespie is
blowing it this week oh shoot Schmidt
okay well just comment briefly again you
don't know Steve
Steve I would roll it back and do
Friedman's thing as I keep saying so
listen
but look the point is that Steve clearly
has had problems hanging around Trump
the fact of the matter the fact of the
matter is that that a peer-reviewed
study has been published on the fact
that China clearly is finding in its
interest to a [ __ ] WTO in the first
place you know that might be a point of
agreement the difference the difference
between me and Steve is I am citing a
peer-reviewed study that was the limit
at the Cato Institute
all right all right
lutely you didn't we can add more onto
this in in closing arguments before I
wanna I want to ask a couple I want to
ask one question of each of you and then
we'll get to as many audience questions
as we can okay gene do you think Trump
is obliviated
ignoramus I'm kidding gene let me ask
you what something Stephen brought up
which I've heard a lot of people who
have been traditionally for free trade
but support Trump I call this the 4d
chess argument but so Donald Trump he
did I believe it was at one of the g7
meetings where he did say how about we
just eliminate all the tariffs since
you're just conceded the idea that
tariffs the full brunt is not borne by
the Americans it does hurt the Chinese
as well if theoretically by threatening
to elevate tariffs
it was it resulted in freer trade would
you then say that this strategy was
ultimately successful may I should say
yes but yes but we have a bloviating
ignoramus who believes that trade
deficits are always red ink so how can
you trust him yes but we have a
bloviating ignoramus who signed a deal
with China that's not gonna work out
who's threatening higher tariffs the
burden of proof is on the other side to
demonstrate that this could possibly
work the violation of our right for some
greater good and I don't even think that
it's that good the fact is that it's the
imports from China that matter not the
experts we already have a full
employment economy so from nine ways
till Sunday the burden of proof is on
Steve and and he cannot bear that burden
okay and let me ask you Steven because
this was a gene touched on this in his
opening as well so you've said that the
the issue of art of our time is not
climate change or any of this other
stuff it's who's gonna be the superpower
America or China but you also said that
communism is back in China if we've
learned anything from the 20th century
it's that communism is a guaranteed
failure so doesn't that kind of resolve
itself
if communism is back is there any chance
that they're gonna be a superpower no
I'm gonna bet on the United States I'm
gonna bet on Silicon Valley and I'm
gonna bet on our entrepreneurs and our
innovators no question about it I mean I
really but it is true they've been
growing like gangbusters you know I
think it's actually sad what's happened
in China and this is one of the reasons
you know a gene that I actually
supportive of Trump when it comes
especially to China because look we in
my opinion we are in a new cold war with
China and we better start realizing it
look at that not just their abuse of a
predatory trade practices but look at
what they're doing in terms of building
up their military their aggressive
stance in the China South Sea I mean I
actually do believe I comply I hope and
pray I'm wrong about this I think we're
looking at China that's Japan circa 1936
I really do I think they are they have
designs of taking you
/ and you ask the people to look out for
a harbor yeah what look out for oh look
and I think well you know we shouldn't
make the mistake that we did you know
back in the 1930s of just ignoring Japan
as they got bigger and bigger and bigger
and then we had to be in a war we should
be very suspicious of this communist
regime we are in a new Cold War and if
you have and and I would go beyond that
I would say they were once you know an
ally and a friend that they're no longer
a friend they are an enemy and they are
a menace and we should treat them as
such a brief condo serf real trade with
the country like that works out so well
Wow okay brief brief comment brief
comment if Steve is basically endorsing
the planned pivot to Asia if you're
going to support the pivot to Asia I ask
you what happened when the u.s. pivoted
to the Middle East the awful bloodshed
and catastrophes that occurred if there
is a threat from China if there is a
threat from China then tell Japan may I
finish please Steve I allowed you to
talk I believe that if there's a threat
from China than Japan and Vietnam and
the Philippines and then Russia and
India which are all in that theater
should be told to deal with it u.s.
involvement does more harm than good
vastly more harm than good and for Steve
to beat the war drum is a very dangerous
policy for anybody who can't contemplate
the hundreds of millions millions dead
from our pivot to the Middle East
we should tell those local nations who
are well able to protect themselves
Japan and the rest of them if you're
worried about China being a bully in
your backyard then do something about it
but but our government does more harm
than good when it gets involved all
right okay let's let's get to some
audience questions before we start wars
in the in Asia we're gonna at least
fight a war with Iran okay sir
so right here with the the snake don't
tread on me oh no that's a Cobra Kai
sure okay
either way it's libertarian okay go
ahead so what's your question my
question is receive so I think it sounds
like you're making a political argument
you're saying you we think we all agree
on the economics of it that tariffs are
bad for both sides whatever you're
making a political argument that we do
it and in the long run they'll end up
doing what we want because it hurts them
okay so that's the optimistic view
I'm wonder ested and what is your
pessimistic view well how long do you
take this let's say it goes on for years
it gets really really bad what point do
you say okay this is too much we can't
do this anymore
right very good question it's a very
good question look I think Trump had it
exactly right that China could not
withstand you know these tariffs and
that they would cry uncle pretty quickly
and they did you know after two years
and let's be very clear about this China
caved in we and and one other point and
Jeana I'd like your your response to
this there in my opinion there was not a
single thing that Donald Trump was
asking of China lower your tariffs stop
stealing our intellectual property stop
the force technology transfers where if
a company wants to do business in China
they effectively have to give up their
ownership none of those things are
unreasonable so I want to throw this to
you do you think there's anything that
Donald Trump was asking of China that
was not a reasonable demand if that's
all reasonable fine what's unreasonable
what's unreasonable is for anybody to
any government to use its Iron Fist to
impose taxes on us because he wants us
to agree with him about what China is
doing my reaction personally is that
would have been if I want to voluntarily
participate in the boy kind of Chinese
goods I would have said we've got fifty
other problems in this world that are
far more important than what China is
doing we invest a trillion dollars a
year in intellectual property we now
have a three and a half percent
unemployment rate we don't want to
jeopardize our growth we don't want to
pay a price and we don't want to be
led by a bloviating ignoramus who thinks
all trade deficits are red ink this is
not somebody I can trust so how can he
be uploaded you know even Remus if he's
created the best economy for the United
States in 30 years
creator well we cut regulation we
promote American I'm sure you got
government up the back up is best we
want to trade Wars I mean that's a
pretty good record now we have the
lowest unemployment rate in 50 years the
lowest inflation rate in 50 years the
lowest interest rates in 50 years the
biggest wage gains in 30 years and you
know what's not to like about that
picture
we've got 2% gene-gene a quick response
effects of interest even I'm surprised
surprised at you because the truth is
that we have a 2% growth rate that's
[ __ ]
2% to and half of [ __ ] that's a huge
improvement over one point nine percent
under Obama yes right we wanted 3% we
haven't gotten there but you my god this
is the best economy for the US and at
least 30 years and this ignoramus
somehow did it even with the trade war
ok ok all right everybody calm down no
no no heckling please and we don't use
the term we I'm a comedian I contribute
to no economy whatsoever we would all
starve if it was just for me so let's
not use the collectivist thing just
briefly just briefly there is the good
the bad and the ugly about Trump's
policies on what treat wait if you see
what I want to talk about the good we
could but we are talking about the bad
and the ugly this is ok let's uh let's
move on to another audience question
thank you this is for Steve I'd love to
get genes response also Steve you
mentioned that China is becoming
increasingly command and control I agree
and that that never works out
but given that wouldn't the correct
response be to free up our economy even
more rather than add to command and
control with tariffs in other words how
do you justify fighting command and
control abroad with command and control
at home thank you it's a great question
and look I mean I think there's very few
presidents in modern times
who have moved towards you know free
markets than Donald Trump I mean my god
Rick that's the biggest tax cut we've
got our business tax rate in half which
is a huge huge incentive for people and
businesses to move here we've we did the
10% repatriation tax we've imported a
trillion dollars of capital from the
rest of the world into the United States
think of the jobs that are attached to
them there is no you know I work with
these people
there is no administration even Ronald
Reagan's administration I love Ronald
Reagan I think he belongs on Mount
Rushmore but the pace of deregulation
that is going on under Donald Trump is
unrivaled and we were just getting rid
of all of these impediments to growth so
yeah absolutely
you fight command-and-control with free
enterprise but you proposed these
punitive tariffs on China to try to get
them to behave that's the strategy we
did thanks for the excellent question
the fact of the matter is that we forged
a managed trade agreement with China
China is supposedly committing it's it's
it's it's partially decentralized
economy to buy 200 billion worth of
goods over there with us over the next
two years that's not free trade that's
managed trade and clearly it's the only
thing that Trump understands with
respect to what Steve just said my only
disagreement is obviously that what
government taxes us really is what is in
line with what government spends and
when Trump came in and he talked about
the waste fraud and abuse in government
that released overspending he then
turned around and did absolutely nothing
about it so that's unfortunately a huge
blot on Trump's record we're running
trillion dollar trade deficits
technology streaming trillion-dollar
fiscal downside trillion-dollar fiscal
deficits and that has been a disaster
so Trump again he's the good the bad and
the ugly the good by the way I agree
with Steve has been deregulation but to
lower taxes and not lower spending as
Milton Friedman sad Steve as I might
remind you another bit of wisdom from
him when is the tax cut not a tax cut
when it's not matched by spending cuts
so jump has not really lowered our taxes
he's taxing us by doing all that
spending and that's been a disaster yes
Stephen do you want to respond to the
the record high spending and the growth
in the size of government yeah I wrote
the book Trump anomic the essence of
Trump Atomics is grow grow grow grow as
fast as you can put people back to work
get American companies more profitable
so they would pay more taxes and even
with our tax cut by the way are you
opposed to cutting our business tax rate
from 40 to 20 percent I'm not opposed to
it but I don't regard it as a true tax
cut unless the waste fraud and abuse is
addressed which is not that I don't like
the waste fraud and abuse but all of a
sudden you've incentivized companies to
move here commands to move here because
our tax rate is now look we have the
highest business tax rate in the world
now we have one of the lowest one guess
what everybody wants to come to the
United States right now
and the same thing you know with respect
chorus chorus Steve Steve I agree with
that point but try to understand Milton
Friedman's but I understand not a tax
cut if you're not cut spending
that's why female tattooers we actually
got more revenues into Juno in 2019 the
united states collected more tax
revenues than any other single year in
american history it is not a revenue
problem in you are you and I agree okay
on that on that moment Steven ACK we're
gonna we're gonna move on I love the
supply-side argument of tax cuts
increases revenue to the federal
government I've always said is my least
favorite part of tax cuts all right
let's let's take the next questions
okay the Atticus to speak all right
question for Jean so you expressed
concern the Trump is a bloviating and
Ramos yeah yeah yes perhaps perhaps news
that a politician would be such a thing
um the question though is do we actually
need Trump to not be a bloviating
ignoramus to to pursue useful policies
like Milton Friedman talked about how
economic models work even if people who
make them work don't actually understand
economics
maybe Trump just has a really good eye
for weakness maybe he knows that China's
only successful global brand names are
Huawei tik-tok and coronavirus and maybe
he just thinks that China has
who's well yep thank you very much I
guess it's possible conceivable between
heaven and earth that a bloviating
ignoramus who thinks specifically said
specifically said that they they're
robbing us what he specifically said was
that that we that it's cost us 800
billion dollars a year and we've got to
get it back I'm quoting it verbatim 800
billion a year he was talking about the
trade deficit the merchandise trade
deficit with China we've gotta get it
back unfortunately if you take him at
his word then he's a dangerous man he
obviously believes that only if you run
a trade surplus with another country
he's a pure ignoramus mercantilist he
literally believes that that you profit
from exports and you lose from imports
so that's in this particular case very
dangerous and he's literally threatened
as steve has just told us to boost the
tariffs boost boost the bloodshed that's
being imposed on the American people
because he wants to bring about some man
it seems as though if you take Trump
seriously that he will only be happy if
we're running a trade surplus with China
which ain't gonna happen if you call
Donald Trump a blow feeded ignoramus one
more time he's a bloke Armus gonna turn
into dan Aykroyd and call you an
ignorant [ __ ] all right
all right I'm fearful I'm limiting gene
to three more three more for the debate
there are elements of truth in both of
those tears that genes wife is in the
back nodding I'm not sure what that
means all right let's uh neck next
question how are you sir good thank you
so I've heard tonight as a potential
remedy to our supposed to trade
grievances with China greater
cooperation with an enforcement of the
World Trade Organization and what I
wonder from both of is if either or both
of you believe that another potential
remedy could have or could have been or
could still be the trans-pacific
partnership uh either one of you guys
want to jump on that one first it was
the both of you gene yeah another
potential remedy partially could have
been the trans-pacific partnership
there are many remedies available it's
very very clear again that we are the
bully in a way precisely what Steve said
we're the supremo we don't abide by
rulings that we don't like so we have
thumbed our nose at the World Trade
Organization and now again I'm of two
minds
I'm only saying that if you believe in
negotiations and you don't want to go to
war then negotiate through what through
the agency that's available don't
violate the World Trade Organization
rulings which the US has done China is a
weakling comparatively and it wants to
be able to get into the World Arena with
other countries that's why the
peer-reviewed studies showed that China
abides by those rulings because the weak
countries do however however as I say
all of this stuff is offensive to a
libertarian like me I don't want New
York to negotiate with Massachusetts
about trade between New York and
Massachusetts that's offensive
I don't want New York City to negotiate
with Chicago about how one city trades
with another it's capitalist acts
between consenting adults and so we
should simply outlaw all this [ __ ]
of tariffs and duties and so
but close down the export-import bank
and fire what's his name who's the trade
rep who's man and so we should do all of
those things radically look I just don't
agree at all with this blame America
first as I said at the outset that's the
data is absolutely crystal clear the
last thirty years the United States has
had the lowest tariffs of any other
country now you may argue that that's an
advantage of ours and I wouldn't argue
with that but our our terrorists on
average have been half what they are in
Europe and one-third of what they are in
Asia on average so how in the world can
anybody say that we're not the one body
by the WTO it's just ridiculous at its
base all these other countries are
rampantly
violating WTO they go to these you know
European you're a crab bureaucrats and
they they rule against the United States
so hell yes I get us the hell out of the
world throat a trade organization we are
the alpha-male economy we're babies
basically saying we're the policemen now
you're gonna play by our rules because
you need to trade with us and we're
gonna have now look on this issue of the
of the TPP that's a tough one for me I
think there were some flaws in the TPP
but in I could be persuaded that Trump
made a mistake in pulling it out because
I do think the best look you all know
from what I've said tonight I think that
China is a real menace on the world
scene and we'd better wake up to it and
the best strategy in terms of dealing
with China is to isolate them and
there's where I think Trump probably
made a mistake in picking a fight with
Mexico Canada you're a peashooter famed
all's guns at China because they are the
villain here well again what Steve said
was a kind of a non sequitur I recommend
that you read the Cato Institute study
about what we do with respect to this
crazy circus of claiming that we're
being dumped on we it's it's obviously
been a crony capitalist carnival that
was unfolded under Obama and that the
World Trade Organization has tried to
get us to stop so the fact of the matter
is we do abuse and we do not abide by
World Trade Organization rulings because
we have a crony capitalist system that
Trump should have
for Obama went along with it loved it
and so does Trump and I bare should be a
stop to it and that should be it should
be off it or should be simply rolled
back but so Steve again has spent so
much time with President Trump he's not
even aware of what the Cato Institute
the people he supposedly respects have
been document in the country that runs a
trade dead look I agree with you this
what this trade deficit trade surplus
stuff okay I agree try and you're right
Trump is wrong about obsessing about but
the fact is we want run a trade deficit
with virtually every country in the
world so how in the world are we the one
that's violating the trade agreements
when we run a deficit with every other
country Steve that's a non-sequitur
but the fact of the matter is that we
still have very substantial crony
capitalist interests that that that the
threat that our US trade rep was
fighting for in order to get them
special privileges and the World Trade
Organization has been imposing this on
stevis has spent so much time with Trump
he's impervious to share information
that contradicts Trump's crazy ex
cathedra statements the fact of the
matter is that we've been engaging in
trade abuses something called zeroing
that we've been engaged in and we can
canoe to do it because we don't abide by
the World Trade Organization oh we're
coming to the end here but it's very
simple my argument we tried your
approach for 25 years no we did we did
we try we treat kept saying oh they'll
abide by the World Trade Organization
there'll be a good trade fair and they
weren't and finally it took the new
president Donald Trump is said to hell
with this we're going to hit back at you
hard unless you start behaving yourself
and lo of the whole here we are three
years later and they've actually agreed
to recommend god I gotta cut you off
there I want to get another question or
two if possible we got to save it for
the for the closing arguments so go
ahead next question from the audience
Steve so you mentioned that China abuses
the US so if the US is the dominant one
in the trading relationship and there
are as you mentioned other production
options such as India or Vietnam why
didn't we just leave the trading
relationship all together don't suggest
that to Donald Trump
look we there's no
over the last 30 years we've benefited
largely from the fact that you know you
made this point I think it's very
persuasive point you know they're given
yeah that's why I don't mind dumping if
they want to give this stuff for free I
don't think there's any problem what I
think the problem is is not the dumping
it's the fact that they have not opened
up their markets to us and my point is
you know and I would argue make this
argument with Milton Friedman what we
can live in a world where we have very
low terrorists and they have high
terrorists and that hurts them but
wouldn't it be better to live in a world
with both countries have lower
terrorists and that is the endgame
that's why I'm so glad you brought up
Donald Trump did we'll go to the
Europeans at the g7 meeting he said
we'll go to zero tariffs if you will
every European ran for the high grass
the last thing they want to do is get
rid of their tariffs so they are they
are total of trade hypocrites in my
opinion but look the best outcome is I
think if China abides by these deals and
we can buy all this low price cost
products from us but they also pay us
for the things that that we produce and
and and pay us for the intellectual
property I think you're dead wrong on
the importance of intellectual property
theft it is it is it is rampant in China
they have no protection at all proxy
property whatsoever Iman brief response
and then I want to get one more question
Sabritas
just try to briefly remind the young
lady you just asked that question that
you were asking this question as though
would I want to buy from China it is
first something I bet I gotta get
permission from the White House to buy
that's not the way a free people operate
if I want to buy something from China
I've got a right to do so very quick I
think that's I mean I think you make a
very strong point if Americans don't
like you know Germany or France or this
country or that country nobody puts a
gun to anybody's head it requires them
to buy these things and I agree with you
I think you know is a patriotic duty
every American should on their own
basically not buy stuff from China I
mean just look if if it's have got the
China label I look I'm
I look for the American label I want to
buy stuff in America that's my right as
an American and I think you're right
there are a lot of Americans who are
hypocritical who continue to buy this
stuff from China and then they want
tariffs on the stuff so they won't buy
it
okay very good I want to get one by the
way I'm starting a voluntary boycott of
hipsters from Brooklyn I don't like that
but one more question if anyone wants to
join me plea agreement all right one
more question and then we'll move into
closing arguments chad has been accused
of being a national security threat
violator of human rights and an
aggressor in the South China Sea and
elsewhere in addition a communist regime
like China's you could argue credibly
that the ruling party driving those
threats violations and aggressions at
the same time the biggest beneficiary of
our free trade is in this instance can
the u.s. then justify protectionist
policies either one of you guys want to
want to jump on that well that that may
by the way you're appealing to my
conscience when you talk about there
being human rights abusers and let me
say that maybe I do have to explore my
conscience for example if I would tell
something is produced by slave labor I
really shouldn't
ethically buy it I would not ethically
buy it I wouldn't I wouldn't interfere
with everybody else's right because
they're not the slave masters but I
agree with you that that that's the
point that we have to look to ourselves
individually as to whether we want to
trade with China it's not a Trump's
business yeah I generally agree with you
and the gentleman I mean you know I
didn't even mention the human rights
violations which are also outrageous in
China I mean you know they've had though
I mean they had the biggest you know
violation of human rights in human
history with the one-child policy and
you know that kind of thing but you know
there's no religious freedom there's no
right of expression and there every
there's all sorts of you know political
repression they put people in jail who
disagree with the government it's a
problem what we do about that I I don't
know I mean I think you're right that we
should all make ethical decisions
ourselves about whether we want to buy
stuff from a country that is
totalitarian all right that wraps up the
the question portion thank you for all
the great questions excellent
and nobody was like too
usually we have at least one person who
gives their life story everyone asks
good questions alright so we're gonna
move on to the closing closing arguments
and seven and a half minutes seven and a
half and you want to stand up you want
to stay I'll just sit you know look I
I'm cut out what I'm out of intellectual
ammunition as who is that
vice-presidential candidate you use that
term Admiral Stockdale many years ago
look you raised an interesting point
about the United States and you know not
you know not having you know goods from
Chicago you know you know New Yorkers
putting an import tariff on something
for Chicago one of the things that has
made America there are many many things
that this America made America the
economically you know a mightiest
country in the history of civilization
but one of them is clearly the fact that
it was ingenious our founding fathers
were ingenious they sent out base system
of it well at that time 13 state but now
it's a 50 state free trade zone so if
you want to see the benefits of free
trade no question look at the United
States it's precisely because people in
Indiana can't put a tariff on things
that are made in Illinois and so free
trade is absolutely one of the pillars
of prosperity with lower taxes less
regulation sound money but the fact is
sometimes you get into a situation as we
I think we have gotten in with China
when we were wearing a kick me sign for
the last 25 years and to quote the
ignoramus that you like to quote I mean
he was right the Chinese were laughing
behind our back at this day they
couldn't believe that the United States
just kept taking this abusive
relationship and I'm I'm actually proud
of Donald Trump even though I don't
always agree with his methods that
finally we have a president who is
staring down China and I think the
American people agree with that too all
right very good
oh very good so Jean you have a seven
and a half minutes if you you can look
at that he's offering you his time
there's a voluntary gift
Steve is a very generous free trader and
given that is a man of great character
in that regard and and I like an
environment personally and unfortunately
however the reality the realities are
that this debate is not a level playing
field
since Steve would have the government
assault rights and material well-being
we must begin by rejecting trades on
Trump's trade war unless Steve can prove
beyond a reasonable doubt that it will
bring some overwhelming good
put another way Trump's trade war is
guilty until proved innocent and the
arguments that Steve has put forward or
conjectural and speculative at best now
I want to read some inspiring words
inspiring words that go as follows
America's most valuable role in the
global economy is to lead by example
our most important gift of the world is
to export the virtues of democratic
capitalism and free enterprise when we
get it right the rest of the world
follows Steve
[Applause]
now probably you know he wrote that's a
that's a book that he co-wrote with
Arthur Laffer and we all know that art
Laffer is a nice guy but it doesn't have
Steve's Eliquis so Steve you must have
written that passage in the
collaboration between you and art Laffer
laugher and so those are inspiring words
and and and then I'll read some other
inspiring words which state will also
recognize the wise course for us is to
move unilaterally toward free trade and
by the way Milton Friedman meant he
wrote those words he actually said that
when he was challenged on when he was
free to choose sessions that that
obviously I want to move toward a freer
world but I don't want to wrench people
who are living with a certain status quo
and so when he was Chuck he said I want
to ratchet down all the tabs by 20% of
here the towers were a bit higher than
any tariffs in certainly 20 to 25 to 30%
tariffs the Trump has been imposing or
obviously they obviously cause blood on
the floor to Americans and it doesn't
really matter to me that much whether I
feel sorry that it's also causing blood
to the Chinese since they are a very
very poor people they we make much of
the fact that China's GDP is almost as
high as ours but we forget the fact that
they have four and a half times the
population so that that per capita per
capita GDP is a little over a fifth of
ours and and we a rich and great nation
are fighting an economic battle with
them that and Friedman continued that
this is clearly the right course for
action on economic grounds now Steve
wants us to pointsme to be exercised by
by a centralized planning government
stealing our intellectual property
rights again though Steve knows Steve
knows that you can't steal intellectual
property rights unless you have some
entrepreneurship going on
I guess the best you can do is poach on
some Apple stores as Steve has said and
so we are afraid of a country that is a
buy unfortunately careening toward a
potential unwinding that's similar to
what happened to the Soviet Union that
is our fear and and Steve who believes
in free markets who should who is proud
of free markets understands better than
us should understand better or at least
as well as any of us that that the only
way you can implement intellectual
property is that if you have a free and
entrepreneurial market and so we should
be sorry for what's happening in China
sorry aside from aside from the awful
fact of the of the outbreak of the
epidemic in China but sorry for the fact
that they have so that that government
is so mishandled things and the best we
can do is lead by example to use Milton
Friedman Wharton Friedman's words to be
a beacon to the free world but that's
obviously not not on mr. Trump's radar
screen he not only thinks that trade
deficits are like red ink he also can
only work through the through the iron
fist and so he's not a leader we want to
follow if Steve meets with President
Trump and and manages to nudge him in
the direction of during a few good
things like deregulation I only wish
you're not Trump into doing a few other
good things like trying to tame our
runaway spending but if treats Eve is
unbalanced playing a good role with
Trump that's fine but tonight I cry a
Corral Steve into defending not the good
the Trump is doing but the bad and the
ugly to continue with what Newton the
Milton Friedman wrote we are a great
nation the leader of the free world yet
we squander our political power to
appease the steel aluminum and
washing machine industries which is
actually quite prescient because that's
what Trump has been doing specifically
we should instead be setting a standard
for the world by practicing the freedom
of competition of trade and of
enterprise that we preach and that's why
Steve and I should both sign on this
constitutional amendment radical change
only happens when people start standing
up for radical change as friedman said
you need those radical ideas on the
shelf because you never know when you
might use them might need them and to
those who say that that i have no sense
of politics when i talk about the the
constitutional amendment Congress shall
make no law taxing imports of
subsidizing exports I say to them you
have no sense of history because radical
change does happen does happen can
happen has happened as long as there are
radicals they're backing up radicals
like Milton Friedman to keep
articulating the need for that radical
change and I invite somebody with
Steve's of insight and his abilities to
rejoin us in that fight thank you very
much
all right very good terrific debater
round of applause for both of our
debaters
excellent job all and Jane if you
wouldn't mind opening up the final
voting now again the the resolution its
we are better than the DNC in Iowa we
are gonna get this thing right here
today I we may have the map who knows
but anyway once again resolution as
president Trump's trade oh yeah I got
the tootsie rolls
I didn't you gave him to me I didn't eat
him I've been on stage the whole time
Trump's trade related initiatives
against China deserve broad public
support that was the resolution while
you guys are voting on that I'm just
gonna let you know a few some of the
exciting debates we have coming up here
at the Soho forum on Monday March 7th we
have a Columbia huh well my copy says
March 7th so we're moving at March 9 is
that correct
okay Monday March 9th come on if you
show up on the 7th nothing's going on no
well it's not my fault Monday March 9th
Columbia Law Professor Tim woo author of
the curse of bigness will defend the
resolution antitrust should take the
initiative to control the size of big
tech companies against NYU Law Professor
Richard Epstein no relation Monday 6th
that's a good one
Monday six free ticket for Steve that's
coming from a Jewish economist that's
pretty impressive
all right Monday April 6th from the Cato
Institute which was invoked 95 times
today adjunct fellow dr. Jeffrey singer
will defend the resolution government
policies imposing cutbacks on
prescription painkillers which came into
full force around 2010 have been a
tragic mistake that should be completely
rolled back to the period before that
before the imposed cutbacks against Sam
Wynonna's author of dreamland the true
story of America's opioid epidemic then
on Monday April 20th as we got to in
April how about that Monday April 20th
the Mises Institute senior fellow Robert
Murphy will defend the resolution to
promote a Christian vision of human
flourishing Christians should support
free-market capitalism
against Reverend dr. Anthony Capello and
the guest moderator will be Judge Andrew
Napolitano friend of the Trump
administration you guys few of you guys
got that one all right I appreciate it
and then I gotta tell you the one that I
am really looking forward to Sunday May
10th the resolution will read a
willingness to intervene and seek regime
change is key to an American foreign
policy that benefits America and the
world the great Scot Horton will be
debating against some fellow named
William Kristol never heard of them
anyway anyway that was gonna be great
bill kristol burr Scott Horton Sunday
May 10th that one is that a bigger
that's gonna be held at the new schools
Tishman auditorium because there's just
that's a big draw obviously and then
Monday yeah it's right well you were in
your defense you were competing with the
State of the Union which I'm sure kept a
lot of people at home Monday June 15th
it in orbs intercity CEO Rose area for
Tongo I apologize to you already will
defend the resolution anonymous
electronic vehicles will create a
reduced Jesus well this is why you're
supposed to get smarter
moderators autonomous electric vehicles
will create a boost in personal freedom
and quality of life and will be
commercially viable within a decade
against Eric Peters who is the author of
automotive atrocities and Road hogs so
we got a bunch of good stuff and then
finally Tuesday July 14th Rega Reason
magazine journalist Elizabeth Nolan
Brown will defend the resolution all
laws prohibiting consensual sex work
should be abolished against the National
Review journalist Madeline Madeline
Kearns
so a whole bunch of fun stuff coming up
here of course you go to V Soho forum
org for all the information on all of
that stuff how are we doing uh are we
are we good we have the results in all
right here we go someone's getting a
tootsie roll all right for the
resolution president Trump's trade
related initiatives against China
deserve broad public support to start
off that with the Prevot the affirmative
got fifteen point zero five percent of
the vote that moved to thirty six point
five six percent of the vote a 21.5 one
percent change whereas no started with
40 point eight six percent and also
moved up to fifty 8.84% a thirteen point
nine eight percent chance
so that is a victory for of the
affirmative so the to scroll the tootsie
roll goes to Stephen
[Applause]
round of applause for both debaters
everybody
[Applause]